[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand on parle de bon matin quand on
partait sur les chemins
à bicyclette
nous étions quelques bons copains il y
avait fernand rue firmin y'avait francis
et sébastien
et puis mme foley
ils étaient tous amoureux mais on se
sentait pousser des jeunes
à bicyclette
sur les petits chemins de terre on a
souvent vécu l'enfer
on ne peut pas mettre pied tu étais
devant pollet
don
faut dire qu'en dit mettez du coeur
j'étais une fille du facteur
un bicyclette
elle fit qu'elle avait 8 ans elle avait
fait tout le suivant tous les chemins
environnants
à bicyclette
quand on a fauché la rigueur vont
déposer dans les fougères
[Musique]
nos vies c'est clair
et on se rouler dans les shows faisons
naître un bouquet
changeons
de ce trail de papillons
et de rennes
quand
le soleil à l'horizon profil et surtout
les buissons
nos silhouettes
on
revenait font plus content le coeur un
peu vague pourtant de n'être pas chalain
achetant
avec paulette
fond de flots qui veut manche à mably un
peu les copains
la bicyclette
on se disait c'est pour demain j'osais
je serai demain
qu'un venir à sur les chemins
agri sigler
[Musique]